testing testing hello everybody okay yes
it's working hi everybody welcome to a
special friday edition
of astro bookshelf hangout i think we're
calling it now with dr brian keating
uh earlier this week he had an awesome
stream with some amazing people
that we're going to summarize here for
you today as well as we're gonna just
take some general questions from you
also uh i put the link to the full
stream that he did
in the description box of this video but
before you go there and watch the whole
thing which you must actually go do
uh we're gonna talk a little bit about
it here together brian and i
uh it's a special friday stream because
i was supposed to be having a
another hangout yesterday uh with the
lisa team
but i had uh a tropical storm to deal
with and it
knocks out internet apparently i live in
an area where just a small breeze
knocks out the internet the storm wasn't
bad we've had worse thunderstorms
in the summer in florida here all the
time so we discuss some wind a little
bit of wind and a lot of rain
but i had no internet so one can't no
matter how good
one thinks one stream is you're not
doing anything without
internet so thank you spectrum on behalf
of deep astronomy
okay so i am streaming on all the things
uh by all the things i mean all the
things uh youtube twitter twitch
facebook and um i think that's all of
them
is that all the things you can't do
instagram because
instagram right they just won't let you
but uh oh
periscope that's the one twitter um all
of those and i'm looking at all of the
chat most of you seem to be
from youtube so galaxia hi peter's here
gregorius is here
john suffel from our good friends in the
uk is also here and larry keys from the
west coast
he's finally able here hi larry gosh
it's been a while
so it's good to see your name in my chat
so welcome guys
for and and uh joining us um
and joining us galaxy said she like
astro coffee much better okay fine
we'll call it astro coffee but it's like
astro
but we like talk about books not
research in this particular hangout so
let me bring up ryan so i can
stop mumbling hey brian you there yeah
can you hear me
loud and clear dude loud clear so uh
how's it been going with you in
california
it's only it's only lunchtime there
where you are yeah i have yet to eat i'm
waiting to eat until
uh until after we finish this
conversation so i'll be grumpier than
normal
also you'll be hangry on me is that it
hey tom van scooter it's good to see you
from twitch
uh yeah so just okay we got to get
through this before brian gives us all a
hard time so
you've been having great debates
apparently yeah without us
right so you went out and had a great
debate and
uh you shared it with your closest
friends why don't you tell us a little
bit about not only what the debate was
about
i guess it's really meaningless topics
like you guys talked about the nature of
the universe or some
small pidlin stuff like that uh but you
had some pretty good people there tell
us a little bit about it
yeah we had a knockdown drag out you
know
brawl with some all-star no pun intended
actually fine pun intended funny yes we
love ponzier we're going to lean into it
that's right with a bunch of the
brightest people in the world including
jenna levin
who i did an earlier that day podcast
live with her which got
a lot of attention for her new book
black hole survival guide we'll talk
about that next week maybe
oh good yeah sarah seeger who's written
another
wonderful book called the smallest
lights in the universe
and then i had my friend adam reese a
two or three time guest on the show
he came on to as well and there was a
battle royale between him
wendy friedman who is responsible for
the hubble space telescope key project
in fact one of the main reasons
hubble has a diameter of its mirror of
about 100 inches 2.4 meters
for those of you playing in europe uh
that instrument was basically set up to
do the work that she ended up doing for
this key project to measure the hub
constant that's right that was its
reason for being that was this
justification for getting built
yeah and then serendipitously it
discovered all sorts of other things
like the deep field the pillars of
creation
uh exoplanets etc etc but we
i couldn't miss the opportunity to take
these you know friendly
competitors but they're competitors and
then i had uh i had david spurgle who's
a friend of mine colleague
on the simon's observatory and he was
one of the leaders of the wmap satellite
and so there's a lot of controversy or
as uh captain quinn might say maybe
uh controversy i don't know about
the value at which the universe is
expanding so you know
no big deal just small things like that
so they had a battle royale it was so
much fun
and at the end we agreed to both do it
again
because we're celebrating the 100th
anniversary of the e-great debate the
curtis shapley debate we're celebrating
the 30th anniversary of the hubble space
telescope's birthday
and the 20th anniversary of the
international space station so
you know what else could you want and
they had this fat fantastic thing i want
to encourage everybody first of all
uh while you're watching on tony's
channel please go to my channel brian
keating
dr brian keating i'll put a link to it
in the um there's a link in the
description too
yeah so click on that uh subscribe to my
channel please everybody needs a little
exercise of this finger so do the
clicking do the poking and the prodding
there you'll also see a link to enter a
contest
which just you know ask you to subscribe
and and to my newsletter and so forth
and then
i'm using that as a uh of a vector i
don't know a funnel
to give away signed copies of janna's
book
of sarah seeger's book of my book a
little book called losing the nobel
prize
which you may not know because i'm just
surrounded by images of it everywhere i
go
and uh and then also a signed paper of
the prize that won adam
reece his nobel prize signed not by me
but by adam himself
and then wendy's paper which who knows
she could be the next woman to win the
nobel prize in physics for her work
and she signed a paper the key project
paper from 2001.
so two signed papers by these top
geniuses
in the field of astronomy no one better
than the two of them in my opinion
to sign books by the greatest writers uh
in the
uh in the heavens so please go there
subscribe to my channel dr brian keating
click the link that says king sumo
that's my friend noah kagan's
uh you know just funnel that will give
me your email address and enter you
along with there's already 115 entries i
saw
to win all these prizes so please do
that i'll i'll plug it i want to give
away these
wonderful gifts that were personally
signed by nobel prize winners and and
friends of mine
yeah i i love that idea of signing
papers could you imagine
if you had a copy of uh einstein's 1905
paper
signed by albert einstein wouldn't that
be something it's 80
i actually looked up tony you'll be
interested to know so hubble wanted to
win the nobel prize
he advocated very strongly for it and he
didn't win it uh he
edwin edwin hubble edwin hubble yeah
that's right
not the telescope just not the telescope
that's right uh so he was nominated and
then he died and he wasn't able to
actually ever
be considered for it we don't know if he
would have won it had he lived another
couple of years
but adam was among the three astronomers
that became the first
observational astrophysical observers
that used telescopes
to win the nobel prize and uh i guess i
hadn't thought of it that way that's
what once
adam actually loaned me his nobel prize
so if you do
enter the contest you will win this
nobel prize which is also
edible it's a it's a form of commented
guilt but
do they is that true you could buy
hanukkah gelt with a little nobel prize
winner called
this one's nine years old so if you do
win it please don't eat it
oh yeah well all guilty you know if you
play dreidel at all
in in the uh during hanukkah and you win
the gelt
it's always eight or nine years old
that's right it's not good chocolate
you're not gonna be getting the good
stuff
so that's pretty cool yeah
i just want to comment uh neural net is
commenting on twitch uh that having to
have imagine having to build something
that works for 30 years
what a feat it was a feat but you know
they didn't build it to last 30 years it
got
it got repaired five times so that
helped
a lot with it staying up there but other
stuff has stayed out there for
almost 30 years like the soho telescope
which i've told you about many times in
the past so i just wanted to get to that
comment because that's a good point and
but
tony before we go on i do want to
mention that there are papers for sale
and actually i have
uh seen a friend of mine owns a copy of
hubble's
i think it's 1933 or it's based on the
1923 and 27 observations
and it's not even signed by hubble and
it's uh 70 thousand dollars
wow it's not even signed it's not even
signed it's not even signed yeah and you
can't get it signed now
why is it working for a lot so actually
adam asked me
are you really going to sign it or give
it away or are you going to sell it on
ebay and then i said i replied to him
adam i'm going to
see who gets more of a higher bid on
ebay your paper or wendy's and then
i'll sell the other one okay i got a
comment because it just happened
somebody raided
the channel on twitch i want to thank
you guys for joining you are watching
a hangout between dr brian keating and i
we're talking about his stream that he
did on tuesday
where he had a great debate with a lot
of top-notch
astronomers and cosmologists to talk
about the great
uh the the nature of the universe and
we're gonna get to what
a summary of that right now but right
now we're just kind of introducing
ourselves and getting started so welcome
to everybody who raided the channel i
appreciate it
and i am looking at your comments so all
right so here we go
um you uh so tell us
so back here back to your stream on on
tuesday uh what is in fact
i'm sure you settled it you've settled
the debate the nature of the universe
and what's the contending what's the
contention about it
so really there were two uh very
strenuous
uh debates really between wendy friedman
uh and adam on one side debating each
other and then david spurgle
on the other and and really it comes
down to what is the value of the hubble
constant
it's it's something that hubble himself
was obviously very curious about and i
made some slides
and i'll send the copy of the slides and
the transcript to everybody who
registers
i had the the the talk transcribed by
some
uh you know lowly paid graduate students
no no i i paid for it to get transcribed
on the internet somewhere
um so i'll send you that but it's the
first time that all three of them have
ever been together debating this and i
showed
uh hubble's original data that he used
to very
um to very sort of bravely extrapolate
from just a few samples
of galaxies relatively nearby that the
universe is expanding and that its
expansion
was expanding enormously rapidly in fact
it was way too rapid
about seven times larger than the
currently accepted value
so and it was uh presented without
really characterizing how uncertain the
results were so we were all joking if
our students
turned in data that looked like hubble's
they'd probably get an f
but then we talked so wendy and adam
were debating because they have two
different techniques obviously adam uses
techniques
related to supernovae and what are
called cepheid
variables and those were of course the
very first objects that hubble
used thanks to henrietta swan levitt uh
measurements in what we now call
levitt's law in 1911
we now know that cepheids can be used as
rulers that stretch out across the
entirety of the universe more or less
to provide a accurate measurement of
distance based on how rapidly they pulse
on and off
so what was really magical about the
evening on tuesday night
was here i had adam reece and wendy
friedman
and jan 11 and sarah seeger and david
spurr all these
like brilliant scientists you know three
or four of them
uh our national academy members i think
all of them are
you know our best-selling authors in the
case of jen 11 uh
and and she has this wonderful new book
and for those of you who like podcasts
tim ferriss featured her twice this year
on his podcast uh i'm hoping that's a
big podcast
that's a very good podcast and so i'm um
uh she's just so gracious and
she um and she and wendy friedman and
sarah seeger
were talking about the impact of women
in astronomy and so there were three men
and three women and we were remarking
how different
uh astronomy is than when henrietta
levitt was this deaf astronomer working
basically undercover as a computer
taking data and in her spare time
becoming one of the world's foremost
astronomers
sadly not living long enough to see the
fruits of her labor
really blossom as it did with hubble uh
characterizing the expansion of the
universe for the first time with some
reasonable level of accuracy of course
he was off by a factor of seven so we
talked about
why was he so far off why that wasn't
such a bad thing
and um and then how it later informed
people like this guy
over here albert einstein and made him
change his opinions about the nature of
gravity which is janet levin's specialty
so we had this incredible
dialogue about the history of astronomy
the history of women in astronomy
the impact of observational astronomy
on on theoretical cosmology
and finally we had this very vigorous
debate on who's right
because right now there's a five sigma
which means you know a part in
several million chance of happening
accidentally by statistical fluke
there's a five sigma discrepancy between
measurements done by people like adam
and people like wendy using
starlight of various kinds either
supernova starlight
or what wendy uses called red giant
stars
and then what david spurgle and i use
which is using
the early universe's expansion rate
propagated
forwards in time to the present day to
compare to
these two different values and you get a
completely different value it's like you
measure one of my
two-year-old twins and you say that
they're going to be so tall when they're
fully grown and then you come back and
check on them based on their
forecasts when they're young you'd say
that they should be you know six feet
tall maybe
and then it turns out they're you know
they're they're you know at least 20
you know maybe even bigger so they're
six seven feet tall something like that
and in the case of the astronomical that
can't be done by fluke it's almost
it's i mean according to statistical
probability the chance of getting this
wrong
is incredibly low so it was interesting
to fight it out
but so what that means is somebody's
wrong right i mean
and they're both so extremely confident
right but
i mean that's that's the that's the
conundrum here when you know something
to within
such small error bars according to your
theories and procedures
then there's god and and they're wildly
different then you're probably i think
and i'm just a neophyte here
you're probably not measuring what you
think you're measuring in one of the two
situations now if i had a guess i would
say the type 1a supernova people
probably have
a little more work to do because i think
cp variables are certainly understood
but the type 1a supernovae uh
maybe there's something there i don't
know what do you think yeah well that
was the interesting thing that they
started off
you know debating not not necessarily
who is right but who's wrong
and who's likely to be wrong right
depends on
uh you know kind of your camp but what's
interesting is that
in the middle of it adam is like texting
me
new data to to show in the conversation
that had really recently
come in and that that was you know
sort of revelatory for me to see how
overwhelming the evidence was
uh in favor of the supernova data which
is the opposite side
of the of the case that i would take
from the kazakh microwave background
side
uh and so it was just really amusing to
me to see like there's this overwhelming
evidence and i've been thinking a lot
about in this political season
we haven't talked and seal up before the
election right yeah
difference between scientific debates
and political debates
and i think the hallmark of what i um of
what i see
is is that we have a desire in science
to go where the evidence goes
and if the evidence is overwhelming as
we as we think it might be
we should change our minds but right now
the evidence is overwhelming on both
sides
and i think the ultimate resolution that
i came in with beforehand
i i totally over overcame and that i now
think that
it's likely that there's some form of
unknown previously undiscovered
physics at work that we have not yet
fully understood but we will have some
incredible new theories coming out about
it
thanks to the work that these two
different camps are doing to get very
precise data
and now the difference is who's more
accurate who's actually accurate and how
can they differ so much
and and uh right now it's not at all
clear who's going to win but i think
it's going to be it's one of the most
exciting developments in astronomy
currently
i actually think you're right and it
makes perfect sense that there's
probably something
else at play here because remember when
adam reese won his nobel prize
it was based on a completely unexpected
result i mean
you remember this people were so sure
that they were going to find a
deceleration of the universe in other
words a slowing down of the acceleration
of the universe
that they actually called their study
that measuring the deceleration of the
you know the cosmos or something like
that
and and not only did they not find that
they found that the opposite was happy
there was an acceleration going on and
it stunned
everyone so i mean
it makes sense to me that there's prob
not only were we not based on everything
that we had known up to that point we
were expecting a decelerating universe
we didn't get that uh that there
that i think there is something more at
play probably related to dark energy
because it's so well defined
some of the parameters in it that are
involved in this oh well that's not true
the parameters aren't
ill-defined it's what they might
physically mean
that is i think is still being worked
out but uh that's a really good point so
what is so what did the uh you said you
had a wmap guy there what was his name
again
so that's david spurgle so he is yeah
one of the foremost
uh cosmologists uh that works on
he was one of the uh original founding
members team members of the wmap
satellite
uh wmap let me just say real quick
wilkinson mike
michelson and i said probe yeah
microwave sorry
an anisotropy probe it was a it was the
precursor to the planck instrument
that measured the cosmic microwave
background tiny variations in
temperature
of that background that's what it is so
i'm sorry go ahead i just want to yeah
it was actually
the most cited um instrument
in terms of papers and data that came
out of it it was the most cited
uh result of the of the decade between
2000 and 2010.
across all of science it's really
amazing their results really stole the
thunder from the plank team
and the plank team was more or less in
some sense maybe i can say it because he
wouldn't say it but
you know relegated to confirming a lot
of what the wmap satellite came up with
and i'm particularly
proud to be connected to it because
wilkinson david wilkinson
is my grand advisor he was my phd
advisor's phd advisor a wonderful man
unfortunately he died
just before the satellite really got
into orbit
back in 2001 he's a great man great
scientist worked with bob dickey
and jim peebles who ultimately won the
nobel prize last year
but they had been scooped by penzias and
wilson the team including my grand
advisor
david wilkinson but so dave david
spurgle
keeps up the kind of the the mantle of
leadership in cosmology
through his work now he's the director
of the center for computational
astrophysics which is part of the
flatiron institute
which is part of the simon's foundation
that i'm involved with which supports my
simon's observatory telescope
that my colleagues and i are building in
the atacama desert of northern chile
now correct me if i'm wrong but wasn't
john mather the current
he's the project scientist for james
webb space telescope wasn't he a member
of the
kobe mission so that's so
just so the kobe was the precursor to
wmap which
measured the microwave of background so
we had kobe
w map fi and then planck were the three
big measurements
now we're playing fourth generation
instruments and
very few of them will be located in
space actually now we think we can do
most of what needs to be done from the
ground
including oh really yeah including the
cosmic microwave background side and
even from the large telescope
so as we said uh wendy friedman pointed
out in our conversation the other night
that this telescope was made to really
go after looking at cepheids but what
she's doing now
are looking at these red giants which
are these ancient stars that are on the
outskirts
of this uh of this hertzspring russell
diagram that that kind of plots the
color
uh versus brightness of different stars
and these red giants uh
kind of inhabit the special places
they're very old and their properties
are very simple they're they're not
complex uh stars they're burning you
know they're burning
uh fusion in their cores i forget
exactly what they're burning but the
fusion reaction is much more well
understood
than some of the issues with this with
the type 1a supernovae
which are these cataclysmic explosions
that we think are related to what's
called the
chandrasekhar mass a companion white
dwarf and a larger star
that eventually accrete the white dwarf
and cause it to blow up
and then that explosion could be used as
a standard candle
she uses these red giant branch stars
and she gets a value that's not
inconsistent it's a little less precise
than what
what adam's group is doing is not only
the supernovae but also cepheids and
trying to understand them better
and he claims he can get down to one
percent uh
in terms of the the accuracy of the
calibration of the measurements that
he's doing
with these type 1a supernovae and
cepheids and
now they're adding in a third or fourth
maybe now
which is gravitational time delay in
so-called strong gravitational lens
systems
we talked about that this instrument or
this project called holy cow
which is you know worse acronyms have
been invented i know and it's a real one
that's really it's out there yeah bicep
i invented but uh
uh but nevertheless yeah this was just a
phenomenal uh discussion for people to
be really gathered around
this this notion of what is correct is
it going to be
uh amongst the uh the optical
astronomers you know these
these old dying you know these old
ancient stars these red dwarfs
or will it be the exposing cataclysmic
stars or will it be the 110 year old
levitz law cepheid variables who knows
they're debating it and then in comes
plank and wmap and say wait you're both
wrong you're all wrong
we're five sigma away from you and the
physics of the early microwave
background
it doesn't get any simpler or you know
than that it doesn't mean easy it just
means
the physics behind it is simple general
relativity it's simple plasma physics we
think we on
if we are getting a mistake there then
all bets are off then we don't
understand what the causing microwave
background is then we wouldn't
understand
how the universe is evolving in the
so-called lambda
called dark matter scenario so there's a
couple of
proposals that that say you're both
right you know it's kind of like when my
kids fight and
you want to make sure that they don't
like kill each other so you see oh no
you're both right you know
you take the cookie you split it and
take the nobel prize split it up no
no not in science sorry
they both yeah be right tony is if
there's some new physics neutrino
physics
let me just let me maybe i'll be too
simplistic in fact i know i am but let
me just say
aren't so could it not be that with
the cosmic microwave background you're
measuring something
from the early universe 500 million
years 500 is it 500 million years after
the big bang something like that
uh and then you're looking and with cosm
with other the other measurements you're
looking at a period of the universe
much more recent isn't it possible
that the universe expansion acceleration
is not linear it's not the same
throughout the history of the universe
for example in the early universe
perhaps it really was
what i forgot through what is it 67
kilometers per second per megapixel i
forget that
in the cmb yes in the right and then in
the in the micro and then
the uh and then in the type one a
supernova camp it's a different number
couldn't it be that the acceleration is
not the same
throughout the history of the year right
yeah so that's right so
but then you have to explain why did you
get a different i mean it's the same
phenomenon it's the universe expanding
under very simple ingredients of course
it's extremely complex and i have
nothing but the highest respect for my
colleagues that calculate these numbers
but in cosmology once you know what the
universe is made of
its destiny is completely dependent on
its density and what it's made of
and we know properties of of hydrogen
very well we know what temperature
hydrogen uh you know fuses at if you
will a proton combines with an electron
uh to make to make hydrogen as an atomic
species
and yet with the simple ingredients with
height a little bit of hydrogen
some neutrinos sprinkled in uh dark
energy is almost
irrelevant at this early epoch and uh
and and then dark matter
and ordinary you know radiation photons
et cetera
it's a very simple universe you plug
that into the friedman equations
and you get h you get the hubble uh
parameter
and then you ask well what is the hubble
parameter which is the hubble constant
as a function of time
what do you forecast it will be you know
a billion years five billion years
thirteen point eight billion years after
the big bang and you come up with
two different numbers which okay by this
gulp
in probability space of five sigma
discrepancy
so this this discrepancy is a function
of time
and it takes into account the density of
the universe at various times
uh so you could if so what i just said
has already been dealt with right so
that's that's okay so people now
are trying to come up with you know
rationale for how could it be
that they have two different values and
be consistent in other words say each
one is making a very accurate and
precise measurement
but uh but they're measuring two
different things in other words the what
we thought of as the expansion rate
actually we forgot to take into account
how dark energy evolves
it was really really big uh early on and
so you would forecast the hubble
parameter
to be getting smaller with time just
making that up and that's what we see
with the cmb forecast it should be
smaller today based on the value that it
was back then but the fact that we can
measure this when i was in graduate
school 20 years ago
we didn't know the universe was 10
billion years or 20 billion years now
and that relates to the inverse of the
hubble constant is the age of the
universe
so that means we had a hundred percent
error in the hubble and this is not like
in 1960 1930 this is in 2000.
in 2000 we had 100 uncertainty in the
and the hubble uh constant evaluated
today which is why it was one of the key
projects for the hubble space telescope
and instead now we've got a one person
100 times reduction
in uncertainty uh you know before this
discrepancy now the
the discrepancy could be real and we can
resolve it and it could still be right
at the one percent level
it's just one team is right one team is
wrong or
there's some new physics that we didn't
understand because we didn't have the
precision
that we now have thanks to the
understanding theoretically of cepheid
variables
thanks to how we understand how
supernova behave thanks to how we
understand these
red giants and how we calibrate these
stars so the interesting thing about the
stars so behind me i've got a picture
taken by
margaret burbidge the famous late
unfortunately margaret burbidge who
deserved a nobel prize in my opinion for
her work with
uh her husband jeff whose office i am
currently in or he
occupied this office before i do willie
fowler who did win the nobel prize and
uh in 1982 uh for his contributions to
to the understanding of stellar nuclear
synthesis
which is what uh margaret and her
husband and uh and fred hoyle
worked on now what's so uh interesting
to me
is that this galaxy behind me over there
is a galaxy that
uh of the type that when the friedman's
team would use in the key project
but now they're looking even further out
and so you don't have any control
where a supernova goes off so imagine a
supernova goes off
and it goes off right in the middle of
the core of the galaxy that's where the
most stars are anyway so it's the
highest probability
for us to see a supernova of the type
that adam visualizes
now to measure that with a with a ccd
camera like the
kind that he's using oftentimes he can't
really separate
the actual supernova that blew up from a
surrounding star there's just there's
too many stars there
but wendy there's literally billions of
red giants all throughout that image
over there
and so she can pick one far on the
outskirts that's still part of that
galaxy so it's at the same distance as
the bulk of those stars
but it's not confusion limited by other
stars in the same pixel
spraying light into the telescope that
they're looking at and so it's a great
term
she thinks she can get better accuracy
and avoid the so-called crowded
background effects so that was one of
the topics the other topic we talked
about uh because i
i will get hungry and i will start to
eat my my uh my chocolate uh you know 11
year old chocolate we don't want that
they don't want me to die on air
um the other thing that was so
fascinating in addition to the
brilliant history of women in astronomy
uh that these uh three brilliant women
and two brilliant men plus me
were reviewing was uh you know this
history of how women contributed to
astronomy
the great uh the great uh kind of
unsolved
problems that they were able to solve
but also we
talked a lot about uh you know the
nature of things like black holes
and whether they could contribute to
understanding these tensions so
so right now there's a lot of different
tensions so on tuesday i'm talking to
lenny suskin the famous lenny suskin
who wrote oh yeah yeah called black hole
war about his battle with stephen
hawking
and so i i'm gonna do that live so
people tune into my channel subscribe
again use your finger you've been
sitting there you're too complacent take
your finger and subscribe click on that
link
it'll take you right to subscribe to my
channel hit the bell and you'll go live
and i'll take your questions and my
friends here on deep astronomy
i'll try to get to all your questions
for lenny suskin because he's never done
a live stream
like this ever before yep that's his
previous book the
i have this one i don't have the other
one yeah i've been listening to the
other one and reading it
uh he's uh he's just a supreme and he
just takes no nonsense he's such a
gruff you know scruffy guy but he's uh
he's incredibly brilliant
influential and uh and he's generous
with his time so that's tuesday morning
9 30 a.m pacific time 12 30 p.m
uh on monday uh eastern time tune in and
ask him live questions so you got to
subscribe and hit the notification bell
and again please also um uh
sign up for this contest i'll put the
link in there again
uh for you guys to sign up in the live
chat
because uh you know getting signed
papers by adam reese
by wendy friedman and uh and
and signed books by janet levin and
sarah seeger
it's really too good to to be true so
i'll send those out the only thing is
you have to live in america
i can't afford i'm just a simple uh
public employee of the state of
california
so um so unfortunately we're all going
to sign up and send me questions and i
will send everybody
who signs up i'm going to send you a
copy of the slides i showed in that talk
and a copy of the transcript service as
soon as my friends and
i think they're in uh barbados or some
are typing away
an hour and a half long transcript uh
with with all the kind of
goodies thrown in it's not an easy job
so when they get that done i'll send it
to you for free
as well for everybody that enters
because that's digital easy to shift
that's awesome yeah and you know that's
gonna it's gonna get better to do that
they got ai now i think both youtube
and um somebody else has got some ai
that'll do your transcripts
live so you can have live chat so
that'll that'll get easier as time goes
on but yeah it's a real
it's a real challenge right now i just
got to comment on this on this
term confusion limited um i it's it's
for those of you who know telescopes the
the the defining
uh parameter of a telescope is to be
diffraction limited right you don't want
your optics to be flawed in any way you
want the
physics of light to be the thing that
that limits you and your observations
well it could i try to live a confusion
limited life but my confusion i am far
from it
i am not confusion limited i am
definitely i am definitely not competing
my confusion is unlimited though
i love that term i've never heard it
before so in the confusion limited uh
domain all right so
brian you got to go yeah i got to go to
about a minute or two let's take some
questions before i go because i love you
yeah ask him some questions and uh
i will uh i will stick around for a
little bit myself after it's over uh
let's see if i can find so you guys ask
any questions first of all
um scrolling through my chat you scroll
you scroll through yours
yeah let's see uh
now there's people just chatting with
themselves uh here we go here's a
comment from galaxia
interesting fact edwin hubble did not
know he was observing or measuring the
expansion of the universe george the
major
uh explained it to him that's right uh
yeah
actually he thought that yeah certainly
einstein didn't think he was observing
it
and he called them basically a piece of
you know what uh
for lemaitre's ideas you know so
interesting of course he was a priest
and you'd think the priest would want to
bolster evidence for the big bang
because it kind of comports with i'm not
going to get religious here but some
people claim it as the pope
claimed it as evidence and proof of the
account of genesis which i think is
total nonsense
even though i take the bible seriously
but but that's you know a totally
different actually yeah it's kind of a
myth uh that that
the uh the catholics have had a lot of
cosmologists in their employ
uh throughout the centuries and lamented
being one of them but
uh uh it's it's not true that they
they're trying to disprove anything
they're just trying to learn more about
the cosmos so
that's something i like to point out
periodically i married a catholic i
learned a lot about it from her
um charlie's commenting the hubble
constant has been a source of vigorous
discussion for many years by vigorous i
mean
really heated indeed larry kees is
commenting that podcast that dr keating
led was just incredible such great names
if you have not listened to it please go
do so
after we're done here because it is
amazing
yeah and i'll put in also i'm putting
all these things on itunes i've got
some great help here if people are
interested in getting involved with the
youtube channel i can use help with
promotions with marketing with
thumbnails and stuff like that i'm
getting four nobel prize winners are
coming in the next month guys
i've got sheldon glashau who's dis uh
discovered the electric week theory with
steven weinberg he's coming on
i've got barry barrish of ligo i've got
ray weiss of ligo
and i'm putting together my next book is
going to be about lessons i've learned
from nobel prize winners instead of you
know
how i can be go from loser to winner i
suppose
um but uh but it's going to have all my
interviews with these wonderful nobel
prize winners adam reece
duncan haldane carl wyman and the
commonalities and kind of their
tactics tricks and tools sort of like uh
tim ferriss wrote this book tools of
titans
i'm working on an analog of that called
lessons from laureates that i hope to
put out before the end of the year
and i'd love to get help on that from
people that are interested so send me an
email sign up for my newsletter at
brianketing.com and be in touch i would
love to get help with it
yeah man this is great access guys i
can't tell you what a great resource
this is for you
uh these are these are not just anybody
that brian's talking to these are
big big names these are the biggest and
they're in their fields
i couldn't help noticing in your book
behind you that right next to jackson's
e
m book which uh gave me grief uh more
great than i can say
you've also got kip thorne's gravitation
book now i happen to read that
uh just you know right after it came out
i read it in about a week how about you
have you uh have you gone through it yet
yeah i read it every time i'm in the
bathroom in the bathroom yeah exactly
it's like it's this is a
book on ground here i mean literally kip
thorne has written the book on gravity
right and it's
literally it is it is like a thousand
page book that's sitting there behind
him
uh kip thorne is somebody you should
talk to as well i have him scheduled
he is you do yep he's coming on the show
hopefully in january
so that'll be uh i know yeah that's
going to be amazing i'm going to talk to
him about also his work in the movies
but you're right that book meisner
thorne and wheeler it doubles as a
weight you know
instead of going to the gym you could
exercise using a gravitational field
um so yeah guys this has been great
thornton rockstar he really is well
john's got john sulfur has a real quick
question then you can go
um if the hubble constant is shown to be
wrong uh would that negate the need for
dark energy
oh if the hubble constant is wrong so
you can have a hubble constant
without dark energy whatsoever in fact
that's what we thought it was
uh that's the way that we thought things
were back in the early
um you know uh back before we knew the
existence of of dark matter
or sorry dark energy we um you know
that's all we really supposed is that
there was no dark energy
and and that there was just there was a
hubble constant so we know there's a
hubble console we know the universe is
expanding there's no
there's no doubt about it yeah so okay
uh as far as what dark energy actually
is though that's the who knows
um we'll talk about yeah even adam will
say you know we know less about that
than we know about dark matter
and we don't know that much about dark
matter that's not saying much is it i
know
it's exactly right dr brian keating uh
author of losing the nobel prize also
running a runner of his own youtube
channel and the
uh host of the podcast um can give us
the name of your podcast again i always
the into the impossible podcast in the
in the chat room as well and then i will
put in
a um i'll put in a link to join my
mailing list please
and then you can get that there and i
will put a link to
um uh to this contest so i'll put that
in the chat
and people can look that up uh please
tune in on tuesday morning
i did an interview with cliff will who's
a who's a fellow
floridian uh that maybe you know who
wrote a book about
um about the uh con
all the various experimental pieces of
evidence that give us
rationale to believe that einstein was
right and it's called is einstein right
still right
after all these years is the old one is
einstein
is he still right and it was funny
because i had adam reese on my show and
oftentimes i get people
that write me things you know and say dr
keating i've got this a great idea
uh can you please help me and uh you
know if i'm right einstein's wrong
but i'll share the nobel prize with you
um
and uh so far i haven't you know really
found someone i'm gonna take that up
with
but he said he gets those letters adam
did and one day he answered it and look
what happened he won
one of these things so
keep in touch yeah i really would love
uh
love to keep sharing all these cool uh
cool videos
of people that are really just giving me
inspiration as a physicist so
don't forget to enter the uh competition
i'll put that link one last time
in the chat room and then uh and then
i'll be on my way to eat
uh some humble pie let's see how that
works okay yes all right well
thank you brian for taking time out um
we'll probably be back next week i don't
know if there's
no schedule permits but if so we'll be
back next week yeah and
and please guys use this resource
brian's doing amazing things amazing
work
and you're going to get access to these
guys and there's really no better way to
do it so
uh definitely take a take advantage of
it brian thanks for taking time out
thank you so much tony have a great
weekend and i'll talk to you next week
all righty thank you i'll stick around
for a little bit guys oh don't forget to
stop your stream brian on your channel
oh yeah i will
i'll put one more thing in the chat room
and i am
out of here all right okay guys
all right so hans is commenting dark
energy is like anti-gravity pushing
everything away right
uh the universe is like a boiling soup
of areas that contra
that contract forming stars and galaxies
and
others that expand uh that's well uh
that's right
it's uh that's a good characterization
of it hans i think um
so neil you it's good to see you on
twitch uh
and neil's actually asked asking um and
like
what about the time before the big bang
and whatever's outside of our universe
neil dude come on man
we have got to get the handle on what
what we're inside of first
then maybe we could talk about time
before the big bang if that question
even makes sense or
stuff outside the universe which also
doesn't make sense now what i didn't say
to brian but